في راي مراقبين كان التنفس على الرئاسه
تنافسا بين رؤيتين لدوري تركيا ومستقبلها
رؤيه تبناها المرشح المنهزم كمال وتستند
الى العلمانيه التي ارساها مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك وجعلها تيمم وجهها شطر الغرب رؤيه
يمثلها الرئيس الفائز رجب طيب اردوغان
وتؤمن بمد خطوط الوصل التاريخيه مع العربي
والعالم الاسلامي دون التخلي عن العلاقات
مع الغرب السعوديه
[موسيقى]
عن العالم كما شهدت العلاقات بين تركيا
والشرق الاوسط قطيعه على مستويات الدول
وقطيعه ثقافيه
لكن الموقف الامريكي من الازمه القبرصيه
عام 63 اعاد الشرق الاوسط الى معادله
السياسه التركيه من جديد حين توجهت تركيا
للامم المتحده لاتخاذ قرار بهذا الشان مع
الاسف تركت وحيده ولم يدعمها احد لذلك
قررت انها بحاجه الى اتخاذ وضع جديد من
اجل مصلحته القوميه
اما الخطوه الاوسع فجاءت منتصف التسعينيات
مع محاوله رئيس الوزراء التركي نجم الدين
اربكان تاسيس مجموعه اقتصاديه اسلاميه
تكون مصر احد اعضائها لتكون حاضره في اول
اجتماعا للمجموعه يعقد في اسطنبول عام 97
ساهم دخول الرئيس الوزراء الراحل بركان
وترك السياسه التركيه في تنميه التجاره مع
دول العربيه في ذلك الحين لم يكن تطوير
التجاره مع الدول العربيه على جدول اعمال
تركيا بان الوجهه كانت دائما هي تطوير
التجاره مع اوروبا وامريكا تحول الاساسي
لتركيا في سياستها الخارجيه كانت عام 2003
مع رفض البرلمان التركي السماح للقوات
الامريكيه الدخول الى شمال العراق عبر
اراضيه عشيه الغزو الامريكي بالتزامن مع
صعود حزب العداله والتنميه اعتماده مفهوم
العمق الاستراتيجي في سياسته الخارجيه حيث
الاتصال بالعمق الجغرافي جنوبا ودائرته
العربيه بما يربطه به تاريخيا وثقافيا اما
وصول حزب العداله وتنميه للحكم قد عزز
العلاقات بشكل ايجابي وكونهم شخصيات تولي
اهميه للعلاقات مع الدول الاسلاميه ادى
الى توثيق العلاقات التركيه مع الشرق
الاوسط والدول الاسلاميه
رغم الاصوات الداخليه المعارضه للسياسه
الخارجيه الجديده الا انه تم توقيع
اتفاقيه مجلس التعاون الاستراتيجي مع كل
من سوريا والعراق في 2009 واتفاق المناطق
الحره بين تركيا وسوريا ولبنان والاردن
عام 2010 تتمتع تركيا والدول العربيه
بعلاقه وثيقه للغايه في عده نواحي نحن
نتقاسم نفس الجغرافيا فهم جيراننا ولدينا
تاريخ مشترك نحن لا نتحدث عن بضعه قرون بل
نتحدث عن تاريخ مشترك لاكثر من الف سنه
معا في هذه الجغرافيا
[موسيقى]
حريصه القياده الجديده على تاكيد رؤيه
مختلفه بسياسه تركيا الخارجيه وزياده حضور
الدور التركي في القضايا المحوريه في
المنطقه كالقضيه الفلسطينيه ما اكسبها
شعبيه متزايده في الاوساط العربيه الشعبيه
ساعه تركيا لبناء علاقات مع دول العالم
العربي تقوم على المصالح المتبادله
والقضايا المشتركه الا انها وجدت نفسها
امام مفترق طرق فرضته خياراتها السياسيه
[موسيقى]
تركيا بالربيع العربي بشكل ايجابي للغايه
لان تركيا دوله تحكمها الديمقراطيه
والربيع العربي يمثل رغبه الشعب العربي
والشارع العربي في الديمقراطيه والحياه
الكريمه بعض من خلال
تساؤل عجبا هل يمكن ان يحدث هذا لنا خصوصا
الدول التي لا تسمح لها بنيتها الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه بما حدث في الربيع العربي لذلك
اتخذت موقفا سلبيا تجاه تركيا
لحزب العداله والتنميه قد غيرت السياسه
التقليديه للجمهوريه التركيه تتاثر
العلاقات بين تركيا والدول العربيه
بالسياسه الى حد كبير لكن مع اوروبا
فالامر مختلف على سبيل المثال حين تتوتر
العلاقه بين تركيا واوروبا بسبب العديد من
القضايا التجاره تزداد بشكل مست
مر بشكل
لكن دول العربيه ليست كذلك
[موسيقى]
تعاظمت الاهميه الجيو اقتصاديه لمنطقه شرق
البحر المتوسط مع اكتشافات المخزونات
الضخمه من النفط والغاز الطبيعي حيث تبلغ
الاحتياطات نحو واحد وسبعه من عشره مليار
برميل لنفط
و122 تريليون قدم مكعب من الغاز تركيا
بقوه اقتصاديه جيده في عده مجالات مثل
قطاع السياحه والصناعه والمنتجات الزراعيه
ويمكننا انتاج منتجات ذات نوعيه جيده كذلك
نحتاج الى تحسين موارد الطاقه لدينا
والتمتع باستقلاليه في انتاج الطاقه لذلك
من الجيد ان تكون لديك علاقات جيده مع
جميع الدول العربيه بعد اهتمام تركيا
باستقرار المنطقه واضحا في استجابتها
السريعه لقطر مع بدايه الازمه الخليجيه
عبر مد خطوط التجاره بجسر جوي وبحري
لتعويض نقص البضائع او تاسيس قاعده الريان
العسكريه عام 2014 في اعقاب ازمه سحب
السفراء الدولي مجلس التعاون ان اكبر
تهديد للمنطقه هو عدم الاستقرار فاذا طلبت
دوله صديقه من تركيا امرا يتعلق بالامن
العسكري بناء على المصالح المشتركه
والاهتمامات والقضايا التي تجمعنا بها فان
تركيا جاهزه للمساعده فان تركيا شريك
موثوق به للغايه في صناعه الامن والدفاع
العسكري
تتصدر دول عربيه كالسعوديه والامارات وقطر
وعمان قائمه مستوردي الاسلحه التركيه التي
بلغ اجمالي صادراتها عام 2021 مليارين
و794 مليون دولار
نحن لدينا صناعه دفاعيه متطوره وشركات
دوليه مؤهله للغايه فنحن ننتج بعض
المنتجات الدفاعيه المرضيه للغايه مثل
المسيرات وبعض التقنيات المحسنه ربما في
الفتره القادمه يمكن تطوير مشاريع مشتركه
بعباره اخرى فان لدى تركيا تراكم
التكنولوجيا حينما يتحد مع راس المال
العربي قد تخرج منتجات جديده
العالم العربي تحول للمرحله الاخيره الى
ماده سجليه كبيره في الداخل التركي وهذه
الانتخابات طبعا سلطه الضوء على هذا
السجال الذي كان في جزء منه طبعا هو صراع
حاويات ايضا في الداخل التليفونات هناك في
تركيا من يريد ان يعزل تركيا عن محيطها
الجغرافي المتعلق بالشرق الاوسط والعالم
العربي وان يعزلها ايضا عن تاريخها وعن
هويتها وان يضعها كذيل لدى الغرب بحيث
تكون تابعه لهذا المعسكر الذي يسمونه
بالعالم المتحضر نحن لا نرى البلدان
العربيه ابي الدول الاسلاميه دولا بعيده
عن تركيا انما الامه الاسلاميه هي امه
واحده وكذلك الاوطان العربيه والاسلاميه